neuer satelliten rekord noch nie wurden
so viele satelliten in den orbit
transportieren mit einer rakete was es
damit auf sich hat jetzt fünf science
fiction herzlich willkommen das polar
satellite launch vehicle kurz pslv
brachte schon so einige
weltraummissionen ins rollen
die indische trägerrakete hat zum
beispiel auch so bekannte mission willi
marx peter mischen und auch das space
cab for recovery experiment ins all
gebracht vom besitzer der indischen
raumfahrtbehörde isro wird der wgl auch
liebevoll das arbeitspferd vom bistro
genannt den namen hat der täter
hauptsächlich wegen ihr pilot so viel
wie sie laden kann mit ihrem vier stufen
kann sie rund 1750 kilogramm ballast
über eine strecke von 600 kilometern in
die st galler orbit befördern
damit zählt sie zu transportraketen für
leichte bis mittelschwere leid das
europäische trägersystem ariane 6 soll
dagegen im jahr 2020 über zehn tonnen
ins all befördern im vergleich hat die
indische raumfahrtbehörde zahlen nur
rund ein zehntel des budgets der nasa
zur verfügung aber vielleicht auch
deshalb knackte die ist froh jetzt einen
weltraum rekord das transportgewicht des
psv ist gar nicht rekordverdächtig was
da mit dem transport eines carola zwei
satelliten und jetzt kommt's 103
weiteren satelliten stellte man in
indien einen neuen rekord auf mehr
satelliten wurden bis dato noch nie im
zuge eines einzigen start in die welt
geschickt
es waren 67 damit mehr als der bisherige
rekordhalter geschafft hatte und das war
russland die brachten es demnach auf 39
satelliten bei einem stadt interessant
bei dieser menge an satelliten ist auch
die verteilung des gewichts der
kaffeesatz weiter gewicht wiegt nämlich
alleine schon mehr als 700 kilogramm
die restlichen satelliten mussten also
alles was klein und leicht sind und in
der tat an bord befanden sich zum
beispiel auch nahm olaf ergebnis die
nicht mal fünf kilogramm wiegen
der kleinste liegt sogar nur 11
kilogramm zurück aber zum nutzen der
mission damit
auch zu dem hauptbestandteil der ladung
der kappe weiterbildet soll jede menge
aufgaben im weltraum übernehmen darunter
ist zum beispiel auch die
kartographierung der erde die erstellung
von speziellen landnutzung skaten und
das monitoring der straff netze wie wir
schon einmal berichtet haben könnte der
bis zum heutigen tag der kleine markt
rund um viele winzige satellit bald zum
größten konkurrenten der bisher
etablierten und teilweise riesig
erscheinen satelliten konstruktionen
werden mini satelliten sollen die
zukunft der datensuche im all seit
dieser meinung sind forscher der tu
berlin sie haben einen satelliten
entwickelt der in einer handtasche passt
und im weltall daten für die
wissenschaft kommen soll ganz alleine
schafft er das allerdings nicht um
fortlaufend daten beispielsweise über
das wetter zusammen sind viele dieser
kleinen satelliten notwendig diese
untereinander vernetzten schwärme können
vermutlich länger in der erdumlaufbahn
greifen als andere satelliten mit der
hilfe von robotertechnik lassen sich
defekte teile leichter ersetzen und
lassen so eine längere laufzeit zu es
wird also ein neues zeitalter der mini
satelliten anbrechen und vielleicht auch
des weltraumschrotts schauen wir mal und
jetzt drückt mir hier noch mal gerne da
ein abo auf sauber nicht vergessen die
glocke läuten ansonsten bedankt blatter